pour toutes celles qu'on vient
d'entendre l'éducation va bientôt être
une priorité comme pour beaucoup de gens
évidemment même si on en parle peut-être
un peu moins qu'elle a donnée à campagne
les quatre partis ont un programme en
matière d'éducation quoi en penser
vincent maisonneuve
lorsqu'il est question d'éducation bon
nombre d'entre vous répondez que la
lutte contre le décrochage doit être une
priorité c'est ce que révèle le sondage
crop radio canada réalisée au début de
la campagne nous sommes déterminés à
agir pour la réussite de nos élèves pour
bien comprendre que les quatre partis
politiques proposent nous avons demandé
à deux spécialistes du monde de
l'éducation de comparer les programmes
et de vous dire ce qu'il pense des
promesses des partis en théorie est fait
pour tout le monde jean pierre proulx a
présidé le conseil supérieur de
l'éducation il constate que la lutte
contre le décrochage est la priorité en
éducation de tous les partis politiques
c'est le seul thème qui appartient aux
quatre partis politiques
michel janosz de l'université de
montréal est plus critique à l'égard des
promesses électorales en impression qui
propose pas grand chose en éducation et
encore moins de façon spécifique par
rapport au décrochage scolaire au parti
québécois on promet de soutenir les
milieux défavorisés
on a bien raison de proposer cela
pourquoi parce que l'on sait très bien
que l'insuccès scolaire ou l'échec
scolaire se retrouvent d'abord et
surtout en milieu défavorisé pour le
reste la stratégie péquiste repose sur
l'adoption d'une politique nationale en
moi je reste sur ma faim quel est votre
plan je vais vous proposer un plan
c'est un peu vide le parti libéral mise
beaucoup sur l'aide aux devoirs on va
pas très bien c'est quoi le rapport
entre aider les jeunes à faire les
devoirs et le décrochage d'autant que ce
moyen là existent depuis longtemps à la
caq la solution passe par un dépistage
des troubles d'apprentissage des la
garderie c'est une mesure qui promettait
son est capable de la véritablement de
la mettre en place et pas seulement de
l'identifier des gens qui ont des
besoins et pas offrir les services qui
viennent
avec québec solidaire promet de réduire
la taille des classes maximum 18 élèves
en milieu défavorisé
j'achète sa voix est une mesure qui
pourrait avoir des impacts positifs les
michel janosz est plus sceptique face à
une autre promesse de québec solidaire
soit de réduire à 27 le nombre d'élèves
par classe dans les milieux plus aisés y
a pas un pays occidental qui ait les
moyens de se payer son secondaire alors
on descend de 33 29 ans m ça va nous
coûter un milliard avec selon lui peu
d'impact dans la lutte contre le
décrochage ici vincent maisonneuve radio
canada montréal